what's going on guys this is Rob and
after finishing up Spider-Man I was like
you know like let's let's let's find
something else to cover right something
else to to go over here and that's one
of the struggles as a comic book
YouTuber is you kind of find yourself in
this position from time to time where
you get so caught up in a story that
you're reading that it's kind of hard to
forget there's still like a mountain of
other stuff there and Devil's Reign is
one of them this story is amazing okay
so it's basically the return of Kingpin
not really the return it's Marvel
actually doing something with Kingpin
now as opposed to you know like you know
King's Ransom or whatever so here's the
thing right this story kicks off about a
week ago and it basically picks up with
Daredevil as you would expect because
Kingpin was originally a daredevil
villain so Marvel's had really in recent
years kind of taken him back now one of
the things that I do want establish here
is that right now Kingpin is basically
the mayor of New York City now for those
of you guys who aren't really familiar
with this this has been going on for
quite some time and it all really goes
back to secret Empire right so secret
Empire of course was a story that we
covered where basically the Red Skull
used a Cosmic Cube to change Captain
America's history uh and that basically
led to Captain America becoming what was
essentially a Hydra agent and then
conquering North America with his sight
sets on the world although ultimately
you know he was defeated before he could
do that and so the way this played out
is that one of the things that had
happened is that New York itself was
basically encased in living Darkness
right technically it was called the dark
force but it was essentially just
covered in like encased in darkness so
no one could get in and no one could get
out what you did have was a character by
the name of dagger who had the ability
to emit light and she was literally
tasked with standing at the top of the
Empire State Building and just lighting
the place up now by and large people did
what they could where they could and
heroes that were stuck there were trying
to find a way out and trying to find a
way to save the world all that kind of
separately save you know their city and
so on and so forth but on the street
level on the ground level the average
person living in their homes with no
idea what was happening they had to deal
with being robbed or or you know all
kinds of different criminal actions that
were going on and so what the Kingpin
did is he actually stepped in and
essentially served as a protector for
the City of New York now make no mistake
he knew what he was doing he knew that
in doing so it would rally the support
of the people so that when the time came
when New York was freed from from its
dark force encasement and basically
everything went back to normal or at
least as normal as you can get in Marvel
Comics Kingpin ran for mayor and the
people elected him right because
basically he was the one that kept them
safe when they had to worry about being
robbed and all that kind of crazy stuff
now the other part of this equation and
this is what he's talking about when
he's speaking with Daredevil right that
when he's kind of talking to him and
whatnot that he knows that in his vault
was basically the secret identity of
Daredevil but when he went through it
recently that identity was gone right he
doesn't know what in the world's going
on he's essentially lost his knowledge
of Daredevil's identity that actually
goes back to Daredevil with Issue Number
20 really it was Volume 5 issue number
20 but basically the purple children so
the way this worked you guys have all
heard of the purple man Zeb kilgrave one
of the things that he had done is he had
basically traveled around really the you
know North America and the world finding
all these different children that he had
fathered when he was being a s IC person
and the goal was to actually conquer
various countries around the world with
his children running those different
countries or those huge sections of the
world and then they would all basically
report to him once the children were all
gathered together they realized that
they had the power to topple Zeb
kilgrave which they basically did but
while this was going on dear devil was
actually traveling around trying to
rescue them keep them safe different
things like that the idea of killgrave
was to eventually take their their
powers kind of hook them up to a machine
and use that machine to basically
amplify his own abilities and
effectively conquer the world and where
all that was basically done one of the
things that happened that Marvel had
done is they had basically had this
circumstance set up where the machine
was used to make everyone forget that
Daredevil was Matt Murdoch they
literally one more dayed his
storyline I mean I don't really know
people were upset by it in all reality I
had I actually had to go back and read
that I hadn't really been keeping up on
Daredevil recently but that's really how
all this really kind of picks up right
the things that are going on that are
kind of leading into this now the fact
that Kingpin doesn't remember the
identity of d Daredevil is not the
biggest thing in the world instead what
actually happens is Matt torments him
right Matt makes fun of him and kind of
pokes fun at him and he's like hey man
like that's why it's called a secret
identity because you're not supposed to
know and Kingpin actually takes this as
a personal Vendetta right he takes this
as a personal affront and so following
that what he does a week later is he
steps out in front of the mayoral office
in New York holds a press conference and
basically Civil Wars the place in the
sense of saying that like all
superhumans out there are basically
outlawed anybody out there who is
operating as a superhero that's a
problem and it's interesting the way
that he does this right because for the
most part people can think for
themselves but they usually choose not
to they usually just choose to allow a
person in Authority tell them what to do
and rightfully so right it's easier to
do what you're told than to kind of like
try to figure it all out for yourself
and so because of this Kingpin stepping
out here and with people trusting him
the way that he does he says like at the
end of the day like we've suffered wave
after wave of attacks right of
Destruction brought down on our great
City and at the heart of almost every
single one of those are superheroes that
yes we could look at villains and we
could say villains do bad things and we
deal with them accordingly but the reign
of aliens that descended down on our
city Spider-Man originally brought them
here of course he's referencing the
events of King and black and saying it
all goes back to Peter Parker that the
hordes of trolls and Ice strewn beasts
that destroyed our homes that's because
we brought Thor here right that was the
war of Realms the idea that like the
frost Giants and all all that kind of
craziness and Chaos eventually found
itself on the doorstep of Earth
specifically in the city of New York and
what he says here is there's a saying
follow the money but with these
tragedies it's instead follow the
destruction and you'll find it leads
back to these Heroes we allow these
unnatural monsters in capes and bright
colors free reign in a city of good
people people trying to live their lives
and when we dare hold them accountable
for their crimes like with the murderer
Daredevil they get preferred treatment a
slap on the wrist and then they're free
to go to do what they've always done
what whatever it is that they want to do
terrorizing violence destruction and
that's one of the things that's kind of
the nature of this right the question
here is is the juice worth the squeeze
is the collateral damage that we
experience as a city worth having these
superheroes or would we just be better
off without them and so he says we here
in New York City feel that is not enough
over the last few weeks I've been
working with lawmakers to draft the
Powers Act recently our friends of the
federal level wisely outlawed
unsanctioned superhero activity for
those under 21 years or age and so he in
turn says we're expanding that right
we're basically outlawing superhero
activity at all here in New York unless
it's sanctioned so in a lot of ways this
really is the Superhuman registration
act from Civil War it's renamed and it's
largely being confined in the city of
New York but it's cool because if I'm
being honest with you guys as much as I
loved the Civil War event I kind of
think this is a little more interesting
because it brings things kind of closer
to home right one of the first question
questions that people ask is like is the
rest of the country going to follow suit
are other cities going to follow the
same process remember with the
Superhuman registration act it was just
a nationwide Crackdown like that right
just day one everyone has to register
with this act it's a little more extreme
and even Tony Stark says that right he's
like we've been down this road before
superheroes serve a purpose and have
saved not only New Yorkers but the world
many times over this is a desperate move
from a gangster mayor in an election
year even kcoa steps in right and storm
steps up and says look kcoa doesn't
really care about law about man's laws
right so do not mess with us and we will
not mess with you right mutants
everywhere have diplomatic immunity no
matter where they go and so that really
supersedes anything that the city of New
York is doing but rest assur if a mutant
travels to New York City and they are
arrested by the forces of Wilson Fisk
there will be hell to pay right I mean
it's just that's kind of The Stance of
CA which is really cool and then
following that the first wave of arrest
began for those individuals who
basically just refus to well to register
if we're going to call it that and of
course Moon Knight's the first
one why wouldn't it be Mark Spectre
right I mean the guys like the guys
Marvel's Batman I mean of course he's
not going to register but then from
there you actually end up getting what's
essentially the Thunderbolts right if
that's what we're just going to call
them I mean they're kind of the newly
formed Thunderbolts here right so like
Rhino us Patriot and it looks like
shriek and then of course like the
female Electro Maxine so like you have
like these these you know kind of
superheroes who are here but they're
quote unquote registered and that's why
this event is very reminiscent of Civil
War and I'm sure those of you guys who
read Civil War are like okay so it's
basically just Civil War on a smaller
scale and you're not
wrong you are by no means wrong because
even during the Civil War event the
Thunderbolts were the group that were
tasked with like going out and like
breaking laws if they needed to in order
to get their hands on people who were
refusing the register and that leads
into the introduction of Captain America
right who basically tells these cops
these enforcers to essentially lay off
and that where they refuse to do it then
everything kind of starts to pop off
here now of course Captain America steps
in to basically save Miles Morales of
course miles has a new costume which
looks dope I'm not even going to lie we
need to get caught up on Miles Comics
right like I love Miles Morales and I'm
never going to get used to Miles being
in the in like the main Marvel universe
so seeing like Captain America come to
his Aid right like the main Marvel
Universe Steve Rogers it's it's always
going to be new to me right it's always
going to be cool to me like it's just
it's it's one of those fun little things
but it's kind of interesting right
because this is one of those instances
where Captain America very reminiscent
of Civil War of course Tony star really
seems to be on his side too but Captain
America's response here like where the
where the guards tell him like you know
like you're under arrest too cap like
every one of you guys are under arrest
and Captain America's like okay I mean
that's cute and everything bro like I
totally understand your your belief that
you can arrest me and and that's
adorable right it's like a little kid
sitting on Santa's lap saying what it is
they want for for Christmas you know
it's cute and it makes for a good
picture let's be honest with ourselves
man there's nothing you can do to me
here like I will absolutely beat you to
death before that happens I mean he
won't but like that's kind of his stance
and so in this ation one of the guys
says like well I mean this guy is a
criminal and the response of Captain
America is if if a law needs to be
broken in order to save lives I'll do it
every single time and so ultimately the
other guys are like no you guys are all
going in and so of course Captain
America helps them to understand their
place in the bigger picture by cracking
them over the head with a shield which
is always the best answer like I always
tell you guys violence is not always the
answer but it is a answer and it's
usually a very effective one right
violence gets things done and Captain
America understands that right Captain
America understands violence gets things
done I mean are there going to be
problems sure but it's an
answer so sometimes you just got to well
at least no pun intended roll with the
punches you know what I
mean but at the same time you've also
got like Spider-Man and Daredevil who
step in so in a lot of ways it's a
coming together of the superhero
Community standing directly against
Wilson fist now of course they end up
basically kind of going to an
underground layer and that's when the
questions start getting asked like why
is Wilson Fisk doing this and initially
Matt Murdoch steps up and says actually
it's my fault and and the reason he
really takes a blame on this is one
because of what we saw in the beginning
with regards to the fact that Wilson
Fisk knew what Daredevil's identity was
but Daredevil had basically engineered a
circumstance to make him forget and the
fact that Daredevil had taunted him but
in the end the response here is no
there's no way that's that's the case I
mean like we knew and even Captain
America says that we knew from the time
that Wilson Fisk was elected to office
it was only a matter of time before
something like this happened right like
Les we forget Wilson FIS is the kingpen
of crime or at least he was the kingpen
of crime he was never a good guy so I
understand what you're saying Daredevil
and sure you being a dick probably had
something to do with this but at the end
of the day like Wilson FIS was only ever
going to do this at some point in time
right all roads were going to lead to
this so it's not entirely your fault now
of course this leads to the forces of
Wilson Fisk specifically uh the
authorities showing up at the backer
building and the reason why is because
the back building of course is working
on what would be perceived as Weapons of
Mass Destruction it's not really their
int ention to do that but they're toying
with things like antimatter and so on
and so forth any one of the devices that
they're experimenting with if used for
nefarious purposes could obliterate the
entire city the funny thing about this
is that because of the nature of Reed
Richards and because of the fact that
the experiments he works on the things
that he does really kind of transcend
any immediate benefit to like the city
of New York and are really more for the
benefit of society as a whole he
basically gets a kind of free pass in
the federal government right where he
basically gets this kind of system where
it's like work on whatever you want to
work on just make sure you use it
against humanity because we know that
ultimately it's going to benefit us all
the problem with this is that because of
of what's going on with the Powers Act
that basically the federal government is
kind of turning a blind eye to the idea
of what it is that that Reed Richards
and all them are working on so in effect
they've been thrown under the bus now
initially where the Fantastic Four or at
least Reed and Susan are like okay this
ain't going to happen right and they
immediately start taking up arms they're
suddenly met by the arrival of Dr
Octopus who basically slaps on inhibitor
collars right collars that basically
neutralize their powers and it's like
yeah man the Federal governments left
you hanging guys uh I don't know what to
tell you and so all they really end up
doing here is basically sounding the
alarm and basically telling Johnny Storm
and uh in Ben Grim as well as Valeria
and Franklin that is a code X7 right
basically the backer building is being
invaded now here's one of the funny
things about this right it's not the
first time we've seen this happen and I
was kind of disappointed with how this
transpired right if you guys remember
during dark rain when Jonathan Hickman
first started writing the Fantastic for
that like Norman Osborne the Green
Goblin when he was director of Shield
invaded the backer building to take over
and Franklin Richards dressed as a
cowboy pointed a fake gun at him but
because he had reality warping Powers he
shot him with a real bullet like it was
amazing it was this just like like it
was small little moments like that when
you saw like Franklin's just reality
warping Powers but Ben Graham basically
steps in and ends up just kind of
snatching him up along with Johnny Storm
and they effectively take off and then
that's basically it right I mean they
they get out of there as fast as they
can at that point it switches over to
Luke Cage and Jessica Jones obligatory
appearance in the comics the reason why
I say obligatory is because this is one
of those instances where Jessica Jones
up here so that Marvel can remind us she
still exists right like she's still
there guys uh she's she still exists in
Marvel Comics just so you know here's
some stories that involve her she is
there with Luke Cage and Luke Cage was
supposed to have a tie into this event
but basically they ended up canceling it
and I don't know why cuz he has an
amazing moment here but basically like
where he and Jessica Jones are like I
mean yeah let's lay low it's why we
don't do costumes right because we don't
draw attention to ourselves I mean
granted like Luke Cage led the mighty
Avengers at one point so people know who
they are but it's very easy to lay low
when you're wearing just like some kind
of a coat and like a black shirt and
some cargo pants or jeans and just kind
of calling it a day right where
initially they were content with just
kind of staying quiet keeping to
themselves you know making sure they
didn't draw any attention there's this
great big huge Calamity that happens and
basically Luke Cage ends up you know
getting involved and stepping in only to
be met by the arrival of the Shocker uh
who's working as part of the
Thunderbolts and where the Thunderbolts
would have would have initially had
their hands on this albe it in a pretty
unsavory way right I mean they they're
pretty reckless and they don't really
much care about like preserving human
life so long as they quote unquote end
the threat that where shocker ends up
throwing one of these collars to luk
cage and is like put this on and put
this on your wife Luke Cage is like huh
not a chance right and then like a fight
breaks out between the two right now
ultimately of course Luke Cage is able
to get the upper hand and and able to
subdue the Shocker and the two of them
basically end up fleeing but before they
do he makes this really really amazing
speech right he says like this isn't
right he's like Wilson Fisk is a
Gangster and a fool a big man who's
small who needs to show his power over
me my friends and you this is not just
about superheroes it's about a man with
his grip on all of us he makes it sound
like if he loosens it you'll all
basically be in trouble some villain
will show up or something like that the
kind of trouble that shows him that it's
actually you who has the power here he
says look I'm not Captain America I'm
not Mr Fantastic he says I'm just a New
Yorker just like you and if someone's in
trouble I will do what New Yorkers do I
help and if mayor Fisk wants to stop me
that's fine that's a genius speech
because what it does is it forces people
to accept the fact that they are
contributors to the problem right and
and it's one of the things about on on a
societal level that people tend to
forget right it's very easy to kind of
adopt this mentality that like
everything bad that happens in the world
is because of some invisible Spectre
moving behind the scenes but like every
major problem that happens in the world
is because of people right there's no
invisible force out there causing
problems it's people who are doing
terrible things and with Luke Cage
pointing his finger at everybody out
there in saying that if this continues
on it's because you're allowing it right
by doing nothing you're saying you're
okay with it if you weren't okay with it
you would do something about it right
you can't be apathetic and then say well
I'm apathetic because there's nothing I
can do no that's just laziness
masquerading his apathy and so by
pointing that finger at them and saying
you're the reason why this is happening
it's forcing at least someone or at
least driving somebody to acknowledge
the fact that they are the problem and
so following that what you actually end
up doing is switching over to Kingpin
when he goes to join Butch now Butch
Ferris is an interesting character this
guy was basically a henchman of the the
owl for quite some time the owl being a
Dess Villain at best right like this guy
was never ever ever ever big time but
the perception here of Butch as the new
king pin of crime and even before he
became the King Pen of crime working his
way up the ranks and basically you know
knocking heads as well as getting moves
and promotions in the right places
especially by Izzy is that he is the
legitimate biological son of Wilson Fisk
that Wilson Fisk supposedly had a fav
with his mother a woman named Mrs P and
that basically left him as the the air
here and so Wilson Fisk largely seems to
follow that and saying that he's doing
all of this in order to make life easier
for a son that really seems to be the
main motivation behind why Fisk is doing
this I wouldn't say that's simply it and
Fisk is one to play the long game so if
this is the perception he's putting off
to uh to Butch Ferris I'd say he may
very well be pulling a ruse and so
following that where where basically he
tells Kingpin like get out of here
you're basically met with Mike Murdoch
now Mike Murdoch oh oh my God okay
Marvel had this genius idea
at one point in time that Matt Murdoch
operating on the ground level because he
didn't want people to know that he was
uh that he was Daredevil had fabricated
this identity called Mike Murdoch and it
wasn't like he suffered with identity
disorder he didn't have like a multiple
personality disorder or anything I mean
he did kind of have a personality
disorder in the more recent run but Mike
Murdoch was ultimately just a concept
that he had created there was one point
in time when Daredevil was working with
the Inhumans and one of them their Name
Escapes Me had the ability to basically
bring to life anything they read and in
reading about Matt Murdoch had basically
learned that Matt had created the Mike
Murdoch Persona and accidentally made
him tangible following that it's just a
series of events where Mike Murdoch just
kind of became his own person doing his
own thing and all that kind of stuff I
mean this also goes in line with the
fact that um that the entire history of
Matt Murdoch had basically been
Rewritten which is weird honestly I
don't know how long this is going to go
on for I imagine Marvel's just going to
Recon all this away and it's just going
to go back to Matt Murdoch just being
Matt Murdoch and that's basically going
to be it but because of the life that he
created for himself Mike Murdoch and
Butch Ferris had basically kind of just
grown up as friends who were also
involved in the criminal underworld and
so that's why the success of Butch is
also the success of Mike and also
because Mike's kind of helped him
progress a little bit right Mike had
masqueraded as Daredevil different
things along those lines but it had been
instrumental in Butch coming to power as
the new Kingpin of crime and so
following that you switch back over to
to Luke Cage and Jessica Jones and
Jessica Jones of course is like yeah you
know we we got to get out of here you
all that kind of stuff but when they get
out there they're met by Tony Stark and
so Tony Stark's like yeah guys we got to
do something about this okay cool
whatever Tony like I mean he wants to
get rid of him right because a lot of
it's Jessica Jones making this case
about how Kingpin is is basically
overthrowing democracy or at least seems
to be making himself totalitarian she
doesn't really know how Tony Stark feels
about that because the last time there
was a major catastrophe like this right
Civil War Tony Stark cited against the
superhero community and in favor of
registration but in the end Stark's like
no it's it's different this time one
because I've arbit decided it and two
because it's not exactly like it was
with civil war with Civil War there was
a tangible reason why the Superhuman
registration Act was being passed right
the Nitro had detonated in Stanford
Connecticut he' killed men women and
children and so with all that death and
destruction that catalytic event people
were like we're done right like that's
it right that Catalyst had like set
things off they like we're finished
right we're done with collateral damage
and all that kind of stuff the superhero
Community needs to be held accountable
for the things they say and do right
superhuman registration is the way to go
will Fisk is using existing scenarios to
paint this kind of dark and Sinister
series of events in some unguaranteed
future that may or may not come to pass
if superheroes are not held accountable
I guess maybe Civil War kind of did the
same thing but nonetheless you see what
I'm saying right he's using
circumstances as a reason to justify the
launch of an event that in all honesty
couldn't even have been stopped by the
superhero community in eldrich Demon a
primordial being from the void that
existed before the universe finally get
gets free and attacks earth right I mean
there's nothing superheroes could have
done to prevent
that right so so using these almost
unpreventable circumstances as a reason
to explain why it is that these kind of
restrictive policies need to be
implemented that's the difference
between Civil War and this we're kind of
nitpicking a bit to be honest but you
know we got to create a difference
somehow so we're not just saying it's
Civil War like Civil War 3 just on a
smaller scale but the other thing about
this is we actually end up finding out
that basically Dr pus is working on
something for Wilson Fisk and it seems
to be some kind of portal that accesses
you know another dimension we don't know
exactly what it's for or what it does
but it looks to be the bridge that Reed
Richards had constructed during Jonathan
Hickman's run the same Bridge technology
they used when it came to like the
incursions from Avengers and New
Avengers and all that kind of stuff but
Wilson Fisk ultimately you know Cuts Dr
Octopus off and says like the package is
here and that's when you find out Wilson
Frisk has actually freed the purple man
zebedy kilgrave from prison and it's
kind of a cool thing thing here because
what he does is like he goes through
this folder that killgrave has and he's
like do you know what this folder is and
where killgrave is like I don't know
right cuz he always thinks small he's
like this this this folder is power
right because it represents knowledge it
represents information that I can use
because in a lot of ways Wilson Fisk in
Marvel Comics is very much a Jay Edgar
Hoover kind of guy right for those of
guys who don't know who that is Jay
Edgar Hoover was the head of the FBI at
one point in time and he had information
on everyone some say he was the most
powerful man in the world right because
they had information on everyone right
foreign dignitaries citizens government
officials that if Jay Edgar Hoover
wanted it Jay Edgar Hoover got it and in
fact after Jay Edgar Hoover left the FBI
there were sweeping changes to the power
of the FBI director because of the
threat that Jay Edgar Hoover represented
that people who were talking if you go
back and you read any of like those old
interviews and those old books or
anything like that people were like that
guy could have become a dictator the
only reason he didn't is because he
chose not to I mean this guy could do
virtually anything he wanted to in law
enforcement Kingpin is very very much
the same way he really operates a lot
like J Edgar Hoover as well kind of
operating behind the scenes using the
knowledge he has to force people to you
know create policies or to avoid laws or
make laws that are beneficial to him the
problem with this is that as he's
talking to killgrave he's like this
folder has nothing to use against you
right there's nothing here your children
hate you they want to have you dead so I
can't use that against you you have no
loved ones you have nothing there's
nothing that I can use against you here
but in a lot of ways that's always what
killgrave wanted killgrave always wanted
to have this kind of scenario where
where he could never really have
anything used against him because he
never had anything at all but at the end
of the day when he goes to basically use
his powers on Wilson Fisk it doesn't
work and the reason why is because
Wilson Fisk is one of those very very
few number of individuals that exist out
there where his willpower is so strong
that Zeb kilgrave's Powers cannot work
on him that's one of the things to know
killgrave does not use mind control in
the traditional sense it's not telepathy
he admits photes but a person with a
substantial level or a high enough level
of fortitude right the ability to
withstand the effects of killgrave they
can overcome him his powers will have no
effect on them whatsoever and so
ultimately Wilson Fisk seizes Zeb
killgrave and it's just like done right
he's like what a squandered gift he says
perhaps it's time someone more worthy
possessed it and so ultimately it looks
like he kills zebediah killgrave
seemingly for the purpose of attaining
his power and using him for himself the
other thing that we end up finding out
is that Wilson Fisk has a sight set much
much higher than mayor New York what
he's shooting for is to become president
of the United States and it looks like
he will do it in the same way most
politicians will do it which is by any
means necessary beg borrow steal or kill
but what this does is this initially
picks up basically with Danny Rand right
if you guys recall the last video that
we did that basically the entirety of
New York superhero Community has for the
most part begun to go underground right
that the Kingpin essentially had
legislation passed that basically
outlawed superheroes in the city of New
York and and is creating a more I guess
a smaller version of the original Civil
War event but what this has led to is
Kingpin enlisting villains to basically
play out the roles of people who would
essentially enforce superheroes being
rounded up and basically being arrested
for Vigilante activity right so it's
kind of ironic that Kingpin would use
what are in effect people with powers to
basically round up people with powers
but it's not that dissimilar from what
Tony Stark did during Civil War that
Tony Stark had the Thunderbolts and then
he also had the mighty Avengers right
they basically went around and rounded
up people who were violating superhuman
registration and so what you have here
is of course Danny Rand basically
talking directly with uh with Luke Cage
the two of them kind of having a
conversation Luke Cage telling them look
man like you know we're basically going
to go get with Steve Rogers and we're
all essentially going to go underground
Avengers work out when we're better
together like everybody's just kind of
keeping everything safe and Danny rand's
response is that he'll basically just be
fine right he's like I might just drive
north and lay low just in case I mean
he's got the money and the resources to
do it that while Wilson Fisk is
implementing this anti-superhero
legislation basically his authority is
not on the same level as Tony Stark's
was during the events of the Civil War
Tony Stark could have Frozen people's
assets if he chose to right that's the
kind of leeway and the sort of authority
he had that was given to him both as
director of shield and essentially as a
government liaison right the person who
was basically implementing all this and
making it happen Fisk doesn't have that
kind of authority here and so it really
give Danny Rand as a Ultra rich guy the
ability to just kind of take off but
before he can he's basically met by the
arrival of crossbones now the fight
between crossbones and Danny ran this is
kind of a cool thing crossbones is one
of those little unsung guys in in Marvel
Comics right he just doesn't quite get
enough respect and that was compounded
by the events of of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but crossbones is pretty legit
right this guy was trained by Taskmaster
he's very very capable now Danny Rand of
course is a master martial artist so
he's able or at least seemingly able to
get his upper hand on on crossbones and
we don't really see how it all concludes
all we really get here is that with
everything popping off because Danny
Rand is like 30 blocks away there's no
real way for them to get there that Tony
Stark and Luke Cage and and Jessica
Jones can't really access a Quin jet
that Tony Stark's armor locked down as
soon as the forces of Wilson Fisk tried
to enter into his home so they don't
really have access to anything they
could get them to Danny ran I mean they
could try right but to travel 30 blocks
in New York anyone who's been to that
City will tell you it's going to take
more than a
car right you're literally going to have
to fly there and so as a result of that
they were like okay if we're going to
help this city and we're going to fix
this we can't deviate and try to go get
Danny Rand we basically got to leave him
right the needs of the many outweigh the
needs of the few the guy's a master
martial artist I'm sure he'll be okay
and so at that point you switch over to
Wilson Fisk when he's confronted by the
new Daredevil Electra now here's the
thing and I'm a little I'm a little
ashamed to say this I have not been
reading Daredevil I have no idea what's
going on
here I don't know why Electra is
Daredevil right now I mean I have a
general idea right just from what people
have been tweeting and talking about but
I don't really I don't know the ins and
outs of this so I am ashamed to say that
as a comic book
YouTuber I am being negligent in my
duties here's my question for you guys
should I be reading Daredevil right now
right like is Daredevil comic a comic
that I should be reading at the moment
cuz I'm not going to lie I think the
idea of Electra basically replacing
Daredevil is kind of cool and I'd be
interested in seeing how that whole
thing unfold so those of you guys who
are reading Daredevil should I be
reading it is it a resounding yes is it
is it an absolute no do not read it it's
awful let me know what you guys think
the important thing here though and we
don't really know the ins and outs of
what's going on here the important thing
is that given the history of Electra as
basically being an assassin that when
she shows up here at the office at the
office of Kingpin right off the bat he
was like okay so I was kind of expecting
this somewhere along the line right like
I know you're the new Daredevil I know
your history I know what you're about I
know that most likely somewhere along
the line you would come here here to try
to kill me here's the thing that's not
going to happen right like I get that
this whole thing with you guys right you
guys are superheroes and all that kind
of stuff but do you really believe that
because you have these freakish lives
that resulted in you getting freakish
Powers you can just somehow do whatever
it is that you want to do not a chance
right and as soon as she pulls a weapon
on him that's when he realizes yeah like
you're you're here to kill me he's like
but here's the thing you've neutered
yourself right like you're playing the
long game with the real Daredevil you
don't kill like you used to so why are
you here right if you come here with the
intention of somehow intimidating me and
getting me to stand down because I'm so
terrified of the dreaded electros who's
one of the deadliest assassins in the
world then let me help you understand
your your your place in the bigger
picture right he's like there is someone
who came here before you did and they
want to meet you right they want to
fight you and they want you to meet them
at a particular location go go do your
thing right there's nothing for you here
you're not going to kill me and in a
hand-to-hand fight I would tear you
apart so nothing's going to happen
nothing's going to come of this right go
and face off against that guy who wanted
to fight you because here there's really
nothing going on now the reality and and
really the reason why she leaves in the
first place is seemingly because of the
fact that Kingpin basically seems to
know what she did how she betrayed Matt
Murdoch and that if Matt finds out
she'll lose everything again I don't
know the ins and outs of what's going on
here I feel like I should be reading
Daredevil right I really really feel
like I should be reading this so I'm
going to do that right I'm going to go
on comicy and I'm going to read dar
devil so having said that we switch over
to Avengers Mansion right now here's the
thing Avengers Mansion hasn't been used
for a long long time right in marel
comics they haven't used it for quite
some time and in fact The Avengers
Mansion itself has really turned into a
place of Tourism right where people go
and they visit wow this is where the
Avengers used to hang out and all that
kind of stuff so it's a very very
attractive thing as far as building up
money for the City of New York but the
sub basement of Avengers mansion that
thing is still in operation that it
operates secretly and is really more of
a bunker that's one of the things that I
kind of like about what chip sidar is
doing here it's very Nick Fury right for
those of you guys who don't know
anything about Nick Fury and I mean like
old school Nick Fury right the white guy
Nick Fury not samel Jackson that guy had
bunkers everywhere he was the most
paranoid guy ever right and it kind of
makes sense right when you're like the
man on the wall and you got access to
all this information and you know more
about what's going on in the world than
seemingly anybody else in the world uh
you start to realize just how fast
things could go sideways so Nick Fury
had bunkers on top of bunkers on top of
bunkers he had hideouts all over the
place what but one of the things here is
that having this place in in the
basement in the sub basement of the
Avengers Mansion it's a place that
hasn't been accessed for quite some time
now one of the other things that goes on
here and this is a really really cool
concept and it's one of the reasons why
so many people were pissed off that the
luk cage tie in for Devil's Reign was
cancelled is that Tony Stark ends up
realizing there's a handful of kids who
are sitting outside the building and
they basically record that Tony Stark's
here of course no one's supposed to know
that they're going to the sub basement
of Avengers Mansion so Tony Stark
initially tries to bribe them and then
Luke Cage steps in and says look guys
like with everything going on here right
now even you have to realize that
superheroes being outlawed in the city
of New York that's a bad thing right
that villains are basically the law
enforcement now do you really trust that
they're somehow going to turn over a new
leaf and do good things and so he's like
look like the city is in serious danger
you guys are in serious danger do me a
solid right now here's the big
difference this is why Luke Cage was
always a great character here's the big
difference between Luke Cage Danny Rand
even Spider-Man and people like Tony
Stark and Captain America and so on and
so forth Tony Stark Captain America The
Avengers they're big names right when
people think about the Avengers they
think about like the the Earth's
Mightiest Heroes right like the people
who save us from all kinds of threats
but when they think of Luke Cage they
think of one of us and that's the
difference that's the huge difference
the Captain America Iron Man Thor those
guys they sit up there in the tower and
people don't say that from a place of of
like vindictiveness right they don't say
that from a place of cynicism like
they're up there in their Tower and they
don't care about us I mean of course
they do they say the world but there's a
big difference between looking at a
superhero who saves the world and
looking at a superhero who essentially
looks out for you Luke Cage has never
worn a mask Luke Cage was part of Heroes
for hire he originally launched it right
like ground level superheroes helping
out people on the ground level always
looking out for his own in his
neighborhood that word spreads and so
people look at Luke Cage and they're
like he's one of us right he looks out
for us is the little guy he knows our
names he shops at our stores he buys
food from our restaurants that's how
people see him and so that's why when
Luke Cage comes along and it's like do
me a solid guys right like delete the
video no one needs to know we're here
they're like yeah man of course like
we'll definitely help you out luk cage
right it's a matter of perception now
from there you switch over to Spider-Man
and here's one thing that I do want to
specify this whole thing that's going on
right now this is actually been Riley
and the reason why this whole thing is
going on to kind of Sidetrack from
Devil's Reign for a second this deals
with something called the Beyond
Corporation now contrary to what you may
believe while the Beyond Corporation was
established back in 2006 in the next
wave Comics as far as where aware they
don't have any direct ties to the
beyonders which is a little strange
because the Beyond Corporation basically
consists of people who exist beyond the
Multiverse right like they literally go
into universes and just cause problems
for people it's really all they do and
they do it because it's fun the way this
had played out is that Peter Parker is
essentially in a coma that during the
events of Spider-Man 76 I think that
Peter Parker had basically been exposed
to like a huge amount of radiation which
had basically taken him out of
commission now during that time the
Beyond Corporation had basically gotten
involved in essentially appointing Ben
Riley as the officially recognized
Spider-Man and they did this because
they essentially bought the copyrights
to Spider-Man operating on a private
level which I didn't even know that was
something you could do and in fact
that's what happens to the comics Benin
R's like I didn't even know that could
be done but the Beyond Corporation did
right and because Peter Parker is
basically a broke guy how's he going to
fight a massive Corporation with
seemingly endless resources and so with
Peter out of commission Vin Riley has
been appointed to be the new Spider-Man
and and that's why he is here so it's
kind of a cool thing because as this
goes on you start to realize that of
course he's basically stepping in on
behalf of like Robbie Robertson and
those guys because what you have here is
Taskmaster and Whiplash now Whiplash
cool whatever who cares Taskmaster is
the guy taskmasters the dude I love Tony
Masters right you guys anybody who's
been around this channel long enough
knows I love Tony Master right I love
him almost as much as I love Captain
carrot Captain carrot I love Captain
carrot Captain carrot is a super bunny I
love him right like I love well I mean
not in love but like I love the
character I love the character of
Taskmaster because he's just he's so
under appreciated but when he shows up
things are cool and as interesting as it
was seeing the Taskmaster in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I really wish it had
been Tony Masters I love the character
of Tony Masters but it was still cool to
see that version of the Taskmaster I dig
it either way but regardless of course
Ben Riley steps in now here's a thing to
understand Ben Riley is not an in
capable Spider-Man and Ben Riley knows
enough to know what Taskmaster is
capable of the big difference here is
that Peter Parker would have handled
this differently than Ben Riley did
right Ben riy knows who Taskmaster is he
knows what Taskmaster is about and the
funny thing about this is the way he's
written here if you didn't know it was
Ben Riley you would think it was Peter
Parker now a lot of that's because Ben
is a clone of Peter right from the old
clone saga story so it makes sense their
manorisms would be very very very very
similar but the important thing here is
that you basically have a fight that
breaks out between between the two of
them now the fight's really really cool
right because immediately Taskmaster
starts to get the upper hand on Ben riy
which is exactly what you would expect
right fighting Taskmaster is fighting
Captain America or Deadpool or even
Peter Parker or somebody like the
Incredible Hulk minus the strength or
Captain America with his martial arts or
bat Rock the leaper right like when you
fight Taskmaster you're fighting a
legion of different superheroes because
he Masters and he knows all of their
fighting styles it's what made him so
cool it's one of the things I love so
much about him right it is a sight to
behold especially the fights between
Taskmaster and Captain America those
fights are the stuff of Legend man I
don't know how many of you guys anybody
out there who's watching this video
right now if you've read the fights
between Taskmaster and Captain America
you know what I'm talking about the
fights are amazing especially when like
Captain America's analyzing Taskmaster
as they fight and he's like calling out
who it is the Taskmaster is mimicking as
they fight it's so cool I know Tashi
coat did that recently it was amazing
but here's here's the thing right right
off the bat because Ben riy realizes
that he cannot get the upper hand on
Taskmaster as he's facing off against
him and Whiplash because Whiplash is
basically holding people hostage that at
any point in time Whiplash could kill
those guys because of the electric
tentacles he has he got more than enough
electricity to take those guys out so
that's why he's like one I've got to get
my mind off the idea that hostages are
in danger and then two we're fighting in
a confined space which is true
Spider-Man fights better when he's in an
open space he can do fine in a confined
space but when he's got some room to
move move when he can use his webbing to
kind of get around right when he can get
distance between himself and Taskmaster
then it makes things a lot easier and so
what he actually does is he gos Whiplash
largely because Whiplash is an idiot but
he basically gos it right he's like hey
man so I know you consider yourself an
aess villain but I got to ask man how
does it feel to be like a b or c list
villain where you're basically following
orders and guarding hostages and of
course that gos Whiplash long enough for
him to be able to get the upper hand on
Whiplash and essentially take him out
and so with that being the case the
fight then turns to Taskmaster the crazy
thing about this is that like Ben riy
just can't handle him because the impact
of fighting Whiplash despite his
modified Spider-Man suit is enough that
it temporarily weakens him which allows
hmaster to slap the inhibitor collar
around his neck and then basically throw
him out of the building now of course he
knows Ben Riley Will Survive the guy
crashes into a car and then from there
he's basically taken by Taskmaster and
and essentially arrested right and so
from there what you end up doing is
switching over to the Fantastic Four
remember Reed Richards Susan storm they
were taken by the forces of Kingpin
that's the thing Ben grim and Johnny
Storm and then Franklin and valyria had
basically been whisked away which by the
way I want to answer a question a lot of
people were asking in the last video
which is why doesn't Franklin do
something about this right keep in mind
that one Franklin's not on the same
level that he used to be and two it's a
McGuffin kind of thing right that yes
Franklin can alter reality stuff like
that he can do all kinds of crazy stuff
he's a a Powerhouse in the universe but
you can't have every problem solved by
Franklin right because then that just
becomes the status quo right Franklin
uses his re warping abilities and
everybody forgets the superheroes are
outlawed including Wilson Fisk and the
day saved right like literally every
story would end with Franklin Richards
waving his hand so that's why you don't
really see him invoked all that often
it's also one of the reasons why Marvel
keeps him relatively young because with
Jonathan Hickman writing adult Franklin
Richards the way he did especially
during the Fantastic 4 run and the
Avengers New Avengers run that with that
level of power Franklin could seemingly
do anything right you combine that with
the history of the Marvel Universe comic
that Marvel wrote which is interesting
that Frank merges with galatis at the
end of all reality and is born a new the
two of them kind of being a composite
being that's more powerful than the sum
of their parts and so it's one of those
things where Franklin just doesn't get
used that much because the nature of his
powers is such you would expect him to
simply just end everything and so what's
kind of funny here with regards to to
Susan and Reed is there's not a whole
lot doing there's basically just a fight
that breaks out inside the uh inside the
prison but it seems like it's supposed
to operate as a distraction so the two
of them can actually end up engineering
their own Escape presumably helping
others escape as well but we'll kind of
have to read you know read further on to
find out what's going on with that but
the cool thing here is what you end up
doing is you switch over to uh to Dr
Octopus who was basically working
alongside Wilson Fisk and the idea here
is that Dr octopus's mind and the
technology he's able to utilize would
basically set things up so that Wilson
fist could dominate The Purple man and
then seemingly steal his powers and then
use that for the purpose of basically
controlling New York that with Kingpin
while he was elected mayor if you guys
recall the last video that we talked
talked about he was elected mayor
because of the fact that he had
instilled trust in people that that's
not something you can rely on right
people are incredibly finicky they will
support you in one month and then hate
you the next right because the average
American just doesn't know what they
want right like their wants just sort of
change there's no consistency when it
comes to American people and so Wilson
Fisk in realizing that wants to solidify
his ability to remain mayor by basically
using the powers of the purp man and
that while he won't necessarily be able
to control people he will be able to
influence them right push them to the
polls get them to vote for Wilson Fisk
different things like that and basically
maintain power and as long as no one
knows that he's using the abilities of
the purple man to do it no one will be
any the wiser now the funny thing about
this is that Otto Octavius is no idiot
you guys know that right utto Octavius
is no fool and he knew right off the bat
once he realized the plan of Wilson Fisk
was to utilize purpl man that Wilson
Fisk would try to use those powers on
him and so what he did is he created
neuro blockers that would actually block
the powers of the purple man from being
able to influence him so literally like
like Kingpin tries to use those powers
on him and he's like no you're good man
uh the the influence of pro man doesn't
work on me right those Fones don't
affect me I've got neural blockers but
I'll leave you to do your thing and
basically leaves right of course you
also end up finding out that Electra is
there to essentially face off against
craving the hunter which looks like it
would be a really really cool fight but
once you get to the sub basement of
Avengers mansion with Tony Stark in them
that remember Tony Stark's goal here
right the plan quote unquote for
defeating Wilson Fisk is for Tony to
actually run against him and what
happened is that once they get into the
facility like Luke Cage is like Tony we
got to talk about your plan dude like
you running against Wilson Fisk that's
not going to work that's not going to
happen because it's basically rich guy
versus rich guy right like it's too much
of a tossup could you win possibly right
you're very very famous people know you
right but at the end of the day we need
someone that people are more likely to
identify with right people want one of
their own now in all honesty there is a
reason why we don't just walk down the
street and ask any swinging dick if they
want to run for president of the United
States right like we've had an answer to
that question we obviously don't want to
have to go through that again but Luke
Cage kind of approaches this from the
perspective of like I think I should be
the one to run so while the mayor is not
on the same level as the president the
fact remains putting an average Joe in
such a position of power could
potentially be disastrous that despite
Luke Cage's best intentions he doesn't
know what it means to run an entire city
and everything that goes on there I mean
here in the real world you just got to
deal with New York as it exists now
right in the comics you got to deal with
New York as as it exists now plus
superheroes and super
villains you got to deal with all that
stuff and so at the end of the day he
was like look like this is about beating
Wilson Fisk it's not about your ego it's
not about you wanting to be mayor or
anything like that like it's about the
fact that Wilson needs to go down and
honestly you are not in the best
position to do this right like you are
Tony Stark the superhero Community is
still a little distrustful of you
because a lot of the things that have
happened your history is sketchy there
are things about your own personal life
that the general public knows they would
not necessarily be a f be a fan of right
you're not the best person for this and
so what ends up happening is that Luke
says like are you on board with this and
the response of Iron Man is yeah sure
but obviously there's some disdain there
right obviously Iron Man is not a big
fan of what's going on now how far that
goes we don't entirely know right we're
not really sure exactly how that's going
to happen what we do know is switching
over to Dr Octopus what you end up
getting here is him basically having
this kind of of inter monologue where he
says Wilson Fisk is a small man thinking
small let him hold his small amount of
power as always Oto Octavius understands
true power true power is the laboratory
of the mad scientist Reed Richards with
his wild inventions like an
interdimensional gate so let fist
control a city my plans as ever are
superior and what we end up finding out
is that Dr Octopus has opened this
dimensional gate and then seemingly
brought in Wolverine Ghost Rider and the
Incredible Hulk from an alternate
universe what he plans on doing with
these guys I have no clue but I am
ridiculously excited to find out like I
am so excited to find out so what this
does here is is this one initially picks
up with Ben Riley now remember Ben Riley
is the current Spider-Man Peter Parker
is currently out of commission so Ben
Riley basically took over his place and
of course the police are being none too
kind to Ben Riley I mean obviously this
is police brutality but it's only really
police brutality if somebody's willing
to do something about it otherwise it's
just being dicks is really all it is and
so Ben Riley the funny thing about this
is like he doesn't really care right
like the cops are just are literally
just like beating him up I mean he's
he's all bruised and smashed They smash
his face into a table and they're like
What's your name and he was like uh he's
like Johnny spider Johnny spider's my
name that kind of a thing but like he's
just not taking the cops seriously which
is the one thing as I understand it
really pisses off cops right and one of
the funny things that kind of happens
what we're told here is when it comes to
this idea of like Civil Wars and
different things along those lines one
of the big miscon exceptions is that a
civil war would ultimately boil down
between those in Authority versus like
the citizenry but that's not true
because people's loyalties are not
necessarily tied to the jobs they work
and that's what you're seeing here that
yes there are a lot of people here who
are police officers pretty much
everybody in the precinct as a police
officer but they don't all agree with
Wilson Fisk and so one of the things
that's kind of established is that
they're not going to process Ben Riley
Spider-Man like they just refuse to
process him because they believe that
what Wilson Fisk is doing is wrong when
Ben grim and Johnny Storm show up here
Ben Grim is one of these interesting
Concepts because despite being a member
of the Fantastic Four Ben Grim always
kind of had this role where he was as
much street level as he was the grander
superhero Community right like the guy
on yansy street and that kind of a thing
right he grew up as like one of these
New Yorkers right he's one of them and
you would always see him just as
inclined to to basically stand up for
like this small guy on the street as you
would standing alongside the Fantastic 4
and like facing off against galatis or
something along those lines and so
that's why when he showed shows up here
and he's like look I know you know a lot
of you guys out there don't agree with
what Wilson Fisk is doing right you guys
don't agree with with what's happening
here you're not a big fan of it and I
can appreciate that right because you
know we're heroes you know we're trying
to do the right thing and you see
through what it is that Wilson Fisk is
doing even if these other police
officers here are unable to or unwilling
to but here's the rub we're going to get
our friend because he saved Our Lives
multiple times and he saved your life as
well so we're going to get our friend
and we're going to leave now Johnny
Storm of course basically just like
melts the door and then Ben Grim walks
through a wall and then you of course
have this cop and this this chick that's
with him you know that have their guns
drawn I mean what are they going to do
right I mean with Johnny Storm just as
hot as he is and they fire off bullets
they would probably end up melting them
before they got to them and then with
Ben Grim the guy's basically bulletproof
so like I mean these cops can't really
do anything so they literally just pick
up Ben Riley and just leave right
because what are these cops going to do
and so at that point you switch over to
Luke Cage now again I still say one of
the biggest problems that I have with
Devil's reain right now is they skipped
the Luke Cage tie in I would love to
have seen what the luk cage time was
about because what you're getting here
is basically the followup to the last
video that we did on the main Devil's
Reign event which is Luke Cage running
from Air because it's one of these
things where in a lot of ways their
hands are tied I mean could they kidnap
Wilson Fisk and then just like fly him
into the Sun and like that's the end of
Wilson Fisk right he just disappears and
nobody knows where he went sure but if
they killed him they'd make him a martyr
and what that would do is it would
basically verify his cause the best way
to defeat Wilson Fisk is to get the
people on your side right the best way
to do that is not to like force the
citizenry into following your orders
it's to give them a reason to basically
ignore anybody who demonizes your
dictatorship but basically giving people
a reason to Rally under you as opposed
to opposing you and so Luke Cage plays
this game pretty well in so far as
saying like you guys know who Wilson
Fisk is right I mean yes like you guys
elected him as mayor because they made a
bunch of grand promises and he saved you
guys during the whole secret Empire
event and all that kind of stuff but
behind all of that you know who Wilson
Fisk is you know who's the Kingpin of
crime you know he's got his hands in
virtually everything and you know this
law is unjust you know this law is a
problem so I as Luke Cage am running
basically against Wilson Fisk as mayor
now what this does is it puts Luke Cage
in a fantastic position because it
basically makes him Untouchable the
reason why is because if for example
Luke Cage were to be found beaten up or
assaulted then at that point it's a it's
a felony right you literally have a
politician that is basically trying to
force another politician out of the
picture using physical violence that
would land Wilson Fisk in prison for the
rest of his life and so Luke Cage
basically cannot be touched right it's
one of those things where it's like the
guy's running for mayor the difficult
thing here is getting people to agree
with him and that's what makes Devil's
Reign so interesting is because what you
end up doing is you basically switch
over to uh to a conversation between
Susan storm and her lawyer and the cool
thing about this is that the the
conversation between the two is such
that there are legitimate concerns that
when it comes to the overall country in
terms of what's going on in the city of
New York they see it as a New York
problem right this is New York's issue
New York is the one that's dealing with
like superheroes causing all kinds of
problems and super villains and the
fights between the two and collateral
damage and all that kind offf right this
is a New York issue the concern here is
that if these heroes are not rounded up
by the city of New York right if they
are not basically imprisoned if this
kind of Insurgency if you want to call
it that is allowed to continue suddenly
it'll turn into other people's problems
because these people in New York will
treat to other cities and other states
they'll go to New Jersey or they'll go
to Washington DC or they'll go down to
Virginia in the patomic or something
along those lines right but they'll
basically start bringing their problems
to other people's doorstep and so the
biggest concern here is that if this is
not contained in the city of New York it
could lead to federal law the return of
the Superhuman registration act and of
course no one wants
that because even then with the
Superhuman registration act as it was
initially done Tony Stark was able to
curtail the most extreme versions of the
Superhuman registration act but in this
instance because of what's going on
because of how dangerous more recent
events have been that the result would
be the superh registration act wouldn't
really be able to be curtailed by
someone like Tony Stark and ultimately
it would be the worst possible scenario
for the superhero community and so
because of that the whole thing is we
have to basically find a way to keep
this contained Luke Cage is running from
air and in all honesty he stands the
best possible chance of being able to
end all of this following that you
switch over to zebidah killgrave now
remember one of the things that had
happened here is that the the psychic
prism essentially allows Wilson Fisk to
harness the powers of Zeb killgrave and
to use them and that's one of the things
that seems to be going on here more so
than that what's funny is there's a
conversation that goes on between the
two where Wilson fist kind of talks
about how he's doing this to become
mayor and all that kind of stuff and
killgrave having been around the block
more than a few times is like no you're
full of crap Wilson fist like this is
not about you becoming mayor or anything
along those lines this is all based on a
petty Grudge Daredevil did something to
you to make you forget who he was and
you want to hurt him back that's all
this is right that's literally all this
is you're targeting him and everyone he
cares about and you're going through the
legal system to do it because it's a way
that they simply can't punch they can't
beat up the legal system they can't
assault the legal system or the
political system it's the one thing they
can't destroy because basically you're
taking the system that they support and
using it against them and the funny
thing here is when Wilson FIS is like
how could you possibly know this the
response of killgrave is because I feel
it too it's like a fog in your brain I
knew the identity of Daredevil and now I
can't remember something happened and
where the initial thought of Kingpin is
wait are you the one who did this to me
the response of kill gra is no no no no
no but somebody used my powers to do it
it's a more diluted form of my Powers
but it's my Powers nonetheless it's my
kids somebody used the purple children
to do this to you and me to make us
forget the identity of Daredevil and so
following that where Kingpin basically
goes on a mission to capture the purple
children the kids of the purple man you
actually switch over to what what's
really left of the Avengers you got Iron
Man you got She-Hulk Captain America
Daredevil and so on and they're all kind
of having this conversation over what it
is that they're going to do with
everything that's going on here right
like I mean do they find some way to
take out Wilson Fisk that's one of the
discussions that's on the table the
other problem here is that Fort Luke
Cage the polls are not looking very good
that what it looks like is that Wilson
Fisk has successfully managed to
basically compartmentalize and control
fear in such a way to where the citizens
of New York are actually afraid of what
life would be like if they went back to
the way things were before superheroes
doing the best they can facing off
against super villains but in all in all
operating with impunity but in the
middle of all this suddenly Jessica
Jones chimes in and is like like when
all the heroes are arguing and debating
with each other she's like something's
something's not right right something
feels wrong here something's off she's
like wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute no this is the purple man this is
the power of the purple man and when the
questions asked like no no no no like
you know how do you how do you know that
I mean one when Jessica Jones comes
along and says the purple man's involved
you don't really argue right I mean her
history is directly intertwined with
zebidah kilgrave no one knows kilgrave
better than Jessica Jones does but she
also understands the nature of his
powers and how it feels to be influenced
by his powers and she's like it's subtle
I can feel it but it's subtle the whole
city hasn't descended into madness but
Fisk is somehow or another using the
powers of the purple man to influence
people not control them right it'd be
different if he was like I'm going to
use my powers and everyone's going to go
to the polls and vote for me versus is
using powers to influence fear it's
subtle and it's small and it's a genius
stroke and that's when Daredevil steps
in and says yes like this has to be
Wilson Fisk Captain America is a little
uncertain right Steve Rogers is like I
mean okay look we can go in and try to
take out Wilson Fisk but here's the
problem if we're wrong right if we are
wrong here the whole thing will blow up
in our face we'll be the bad guys right
we'll be vilified any support that we
have in the public will be gone and at
the end of the day what we're doing
requires public support our ability to
function as superheroes lives and dies
based on whether or not the general
public supports us if we attack the
mayor of New York who is out there right
now telling the public that we are
dangerous and it turns out that we're
wrong that he has nothing to do with
purple man and none of this is the case
it's game over that's the end of it but
the the the idea of Daredevil remaining
steadfast is no it is Wilson Fisk and
notice this one of the things that kind
of goes on here is like we got to take
him out right like we have to we have to
basically take this guy out we're going
to remove him from office and when the
question is asked like are we really
entertaining the idea of killing Wilson
Fisk or like disappearing him or
something like that the response to
Daredevil is that's how it is when
you're an anti-hero right we do the
things that superheroes just can't bring
themselves to do Captain America's great
and everything but you can't rely on
Captain America for this right his moral
compass is too strong or whatever the
case is it's our job as anti-heroes what
we have here is a clear and present
danger in the form of Wilson Fisk the
mayor of New York the only way to fix
this is to get rid of him now the funny
thing about this is that they're not the
only ones that have tried to launch an
attack on Wilson Fisk there is a winter
soldier tying the devil's Reign which is
weird to see them just arbitrarily
pulling Bucky Barnes out of nowhere
right and then just like launching a one
shot with him I haven't had a chance to
read it yet I want to uh I have no idea
if it's good or not that's one of the
things about about Winter Soldier man
sometimes the comics are great and other
times they're terrible it really
depends there is no medium there but I
do want to check it out but regardless
because of what had gone on with the
Winter Soldier and all that kind of
stuff the fact that City Hall the penous
of Wilson Fisk right the Mansion had all
basically become compromised there's
heightened levels of security here the
problem is that while they're basically
contemplating how they're going to take
out Wilson Fisk suddenly the forces of
otta Octavius come flowing out right
like the auto Incredible Hulk and wolver
rain and like Ghost Rider and those guys
all come flying out here now where the
Auto Ghost Rider goes and attacks The
Avengers he takes out Iron Man and the
statement of Iron Man is particularly
confusing here because he says no stay
away I did what you asked what it looks
like is Iron Man sold him out that Iron
Man told like literally told Kingpin and
all them The Avengers are coming for you
right like they're coming right now and
they're going to they're going to try to
take you out right they're going to try
to remove like forcefully remove you
from office and that's going to be it at
that point like literally all these guys
you know they're they're they're
standing like they're facing off as best
they can they're holding their ground
but then once Captain America gets over
to Iron Man he realizes it's not Iron
Man it's chameleon right the Master of
Disguise what a genius writing stroke
right chameleon was masquerading his
Iron Man and then basically set a trap
once Captain America realizes what's
going on he was like Avengers fall back
and like get out of here right we have
to go because we're going to die here
like if we stay here they will kill us
because what this is by all standards of
measurement is an assassination attempt
of a political official that's how it's
going to look that's how it's going to
be depicted The Avengers tried to
forcibly remove and or assass
assassinate a political official and so
they're just like like we can't be here
like we can't stay here now of course
it's one of those things where dared was
like no we can't let him get away but in
the end it's just like no we have to go
and so what you end up doing is
switching over to to foggy Nelson right
he's the attorney for Luke Cage the one
that's basically representing Luke Cage
as far as his desire to become mayor and
so on and so forth once he gets to the
office he makes a kind of off-handed
remark of like yeah man I God I really
should have gone home and there's
there's a couple people in the office
who like yeah you really should have
here's the problem you and that lady
lawyer you have you're loud and our boss
doesn't like loud people so our boss has
decided you're better off not being able
to speak in effect the Kingpin has
seemingly sent henchmen to the lawyer of
Luke Cage to foggy Nelson's office to
basically Pummel him to silence him
right it's political sabotage this is
getting messy but oh my god do I love
this now picking up from the end of last
week's video right the last issue this
basically takes place 2 weeks after the
attempt of what you could kind of call
The Secret Avenger I guess they don't
officially have a name they're just
calling themselves The Avengers but
basically their attempt on Wilson Fisk
if anything to take the life of Wilson
Fisk right to take him down of course
they proved to be unsuccessful but what
this did is it basically emboldened W
Wilson Fisk right in the sense that now
they've got drones out there that are
basically always on the hunt for these
different members of The Avengers as
well as anybody who either has
information or anybody who may have some
kind of powers out there the other part
of this is that Wilson Fisk has heavily
fortified the entire of the the mayoral
office right where he resides so now
it's one of these things where in a lot
of ways because of the actions of the
superheroes they've almost kind of push
the city of New York into becoming a
like a militarized zone right it's kind
of crazy but regardless of course you
end up having Wilson Fisk who's met by
the arrival of Dr Octopus right who has
of course his other octopus henchmen and
so on and so forth and it's one of those
funny things because in the end Wilson
fist kind of asks him like you have
what's basically a Hulk and like a
wolverin and a ghost writer and yourself
why don't you just come take the Throne
of mayor for me and the response of Otto
is just basically saying like because it
means nothing to me right like why would
I go through all that time and all that
energy and all that effort to kill you
in order to become mayor right I've got
like much bigger things that I'm
focusing on besides that and it's kind
of the funny thing right because he says
like you've always been obsessed with
power Wilson Fisk right and I'm I'm
happy to have you basically sit in a
useless seat to shake hands and kiss
babies he's like but I am working on
making the world a better place right
I'm working on much bigger things the
technology in the backer building
following Reed Richard's arrest has Lind
basically given me like marvelous
technologies that I can use for my own
ends right that made all these octobots
possible and all that kind of stuff at
the end of the day you're focusing on
small stuff as you always do because
you're a small-minded person I'm
focusing on big things he says also
something that you should be aware of
he's like in the end we have basically
continue to deliver you know we want to
deliver this news that like crime is
again down in the city of New York which
means we've arrested ared your son Butch
and then basically leaves now following
that Matt Murdoch of course goes to
basically visit uh foggy Nelson remember
because foggy Nelson is basically the
lawyer for Luke Cage and Luke Cage
announced his candidacy for mayor of the
city of New York to run against Wilson
Fisk because from The Avengers
perspective is the only real way to get
Fisk out of his position that if they
were to successfully assassinate him he
would basically become a martyr and he
would prove them right right he would
prove himself right in saying that
Avengers or superheroes are just too
dangerous because it's literally
superheroes assassinated a political
official right that's not something to
be done lightly of course foggy Nelson
was basically beat up by henchmen of
Wilson Fisk in order to basically send a
message now the funny thing about this
is that foggy Nelson as you know those
of you guys who are familiar with
Daredevil foggy Nelson foggy Nelson
doesn't take lip off anybody and so it's
one of those things where it's like okay
I mean yeah I get what they were trying
to do but like they're going to have to
try harder than that this whole Catholic
guilt that you have you know Matt
Murdoch of well you know foggy I never
should have involved you and I I put You
In Harm's Way stuff it right and and
even he's he's just like I absolve you
my son now get out of here right like go
do your
thing that's one of the things I always
loved about foggy Nelson right but in
the midst of that of course as Matt
Murdoch is leaving he's met by the
arrival of his twin brother Mike Murdoch
now as a bit of a refresher here for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with Mike Murdoch we did discuss him
before so we won't go super in-depth
here that basically there was a point
where Matt Murdoch had brought together
a team of Inhumans to essentially find a
way or at least brought brought together
a team of people which includ Ed in
humans to find a way to defeat Wilson
Fisk one of those was a person named
reader who could basically manifest
anything he read and that in researching
Matt Murdoch and seeing the identity of
Mike Murdoch this led to him
accidentally creating Mike Murdoch now
the reason why we've never really talked
about him before the reason why we never
really addressed him before is because
in all honesty Marvel will probably get
rid of him pretty soon especially when
you get around to the point where like
the the Netflix Daredevil Series starts
to launch Marvel's probably going to
kill off Mike Murdoch right so you know
we can do a video on him if you guys are
particularly interested but right now
there's just not really a reason to I
don't see him lasting much longer in
Marvel Comics uh and so it's just one of
those things where where you kind of
switch over to Wilson Fisk himself and
because of what's going on here one of
the things you remember in the last
video that we discussed or that we did
that you have the purple man zebidah
killgrave right a person who has the
ability to emit phermones that can
basically make people do whatever it is
that he wants them to do so long as
their willpower isn't too high or they
don't have any kind of like telepathic
protection or anything along those lines
but there was also the purple Man's
children and that his children are the
other half of this puzzle the powers of
the purple man only go so far but if
Wilson Fisk has the powers of his kids
and the powers of purple man then he
would be nigh Unstoppable and he kind of
has his sight set on The Office of the
presidency now remember the entire
motivation for why Wilson Fisk is doing
this is because somewhere along the line
basically Matt Murdoch had done
something to make him forget Daredevil's
identity it's a personal Grudge the the
reality of this and like the equivalent
of what's going on here is if like your
your worst enemy in the world came to
you and basically said that they they
were able to successfully do something
to like defeat you in some capacity and
you had no real recourse that's what
this is the equivalent of right it's
basically Kingpin essentially boxing
Matt Murdoch in saying okay fine if you
are going to strip me of the knowledge
of your identity against my will right
you're going to screw with my head then
that's fine I will screw with your life
and not just your life the lives of
everybody around you this is really
nothing more than a personal Grudge
that's something to understand here
right this is not Wilson Fisk genuinely
doing the good thing and believing he
can actually make the world better no
everything he's doing here harnessing
the power of the purple man you know
setting his sights on the office of the
presidency it's all to basically get
back at Matt Murdoch is really all it is
right and so basically he ends up
bringing together the Thunderbolts so
you got like John Walker you've got
Rhino right you've got the new Electro
all that kind of stuff and it's one of
these things something to keep in mind
the Thunderbolts are really more
anti-heroes than they are straight up
villains they're basically you know
people who were at some point in line uh
maybe Good Guys kind of not good guys
and have a questionable pass well I
guess when I say that I'm really more
referencing John Walker these guys have
always kind okay they've always kind of
been bad guys I mean to an degree with
John Walker he's a little more anti-hero
right he you know the the commission on
superhuman activities basically replaced
Captain America with him and then he
lost hison and that led to him just like
you know basically being stripped of his
powers and then the mantle of Captain
America going back to to Steve Rogers
but is again it's one of those things
where like what Wilson Fisk is asking
them to do here is to basically find the
purple children and that's where the the
villains really kind of draw the line
it's one of the things about Marvel's
villains right very rarely do you ever
find a Marvel villain who will do
whatever they need to do right who will
do anything and everything they have a
few of them like Taskmaster is a good
example right you pay Taskmaster to kill
a person he will kill them it doesn't
really matter who they are right like he
will kill that person Frank Castle to a
degree but only when it comes to
villains right Marvel really kind of
shies away from this idea that like
villains will kill kids they really sort
of they they don't they don't really
deal with that all too often and
rightfully so and so it's one of these
things where literally John Walker is
like I mean look you know I need to know
what these kids did right I mean why are
we going after them and so what he ends
up doing or at least what Kingpin does
is he invokes the power of the purple
man and says like you will do what I
tell you to do Mr Walker and then of
course with Walker's willp power really
kind of being being lower than it needs
to be to withstand the powers of the
purple man ends up going alongside that
instead and so of course again following
that you basically pick up with who is
in effect the wife of Wilson Fisk at
this point in time Ty Mary of course
we'll talk about her here in a little
bit what you actually end up doing is
switch over to the prison where all the
various superheroes are being held where
essentially Susan storm using her powers
to make herself invisible uh having
picked the the lock on her collar right
because she had an inhibitor collar but
she ended up taking a paperclip when she
was meeting with her attorney and now
has used that to free herself and then
in turn steals like one of the passes
off one of the guards as they walk by
and then freeze Reed Richards and then
basically freeze you know opens up all
the other cells which allows all the
heroes to escape here's the thing about
this right on the surface you could look
at that and call this a plot device it's
actually not so Susan storm is
ridiculous L capable right I mean one of
the things to understand here you're
talking about a woman whose power to
create force fields can withstand the
power of celestials so it's no small
thing so it's not beyond the realm of
possibility to believe that she could
basically use a paperclip to pick a lock
on her inhibitor collar what this is
also designed to do is illustrate the
idiocy of just your average person in
comparison to the Fantastic Fort and the
reason why I say that is if you go back
and you look at the events of Civil War
when the idea of creating a prison for
those who wouldn't follow superhuman
registration was created or developed by
like Reed and Tony and Hank Pim really
Reed more than anybody else that Reed's
first thought was we're going to be
arresting some pretty Heavy Hitters
whether they have super strength or they
have intangibility or anything like that
so it's not enough to put them in a
prison we have to put that prison in a
place that they can't escape from and
that's why prison 42 during Civil War
was located in the negative zone so that
even if they somehow did manag to escape
the prison where are they going to go
that's one of the things you kind of run
into here is that in this instance
literally they locked up on all these
superheroes and they just put them in a
prison in the water and like that was it
right it just it's kind of like okay in
the end like a prison break is going to
happen especially when like two of the
people you have locked up right like
Reed Richards and Tony Stark are two of
the absolute smartest people in the
entirety of the Marvel Universe and so
again great big huge fight breaks out
and basically they end up you know
seemingly being able to overtake the
prison guards and start engineering
their own Escape now one of the things
that goes on here and it's kind of
intriguing is that you do have like the
Champions right so you've got like iron
hard and you've got Kamala Khan Miss
Marvel and you got like Viv right like
vision's daughter which honestly I feel
like we should get caught up on the
Champions I haven't read them in so long
but their Comics were just fun right it
was like Marvel's Teen Titans but better
it was it was just
great I just loved it right there's a
great big huge fight even with Miles
right there's a great big huge fight
where like they're all involved in a
conflict with Rhino and it's one of
those things where like Rhino basically
is is like he's here and he was like
look like put on put on these like
basically put on these discs right like
put on these on these things um and
ultimately when that happens the the
Bots themselves or the drones are
basically designed in such a way to
where they don't attack anybody with a
thunderbolt badge and when the question
is asked Rhino why are you giving us
Thunderbolt badges so these Throne these
drones won't attack us the response of
rhino is look like I know I'm a bad guy
right like I have not done very good
things over the course of my life I've
basically just been a horrible human
being anytime you ever saw me I was
committing some kind of a crime but what
Wilson Fisk is asking us to do to find
some kids and to bring those kids in who
seemingly haven't done anything wrong
not even I can can follow those orders
right not even I can abide that right
it's just that's a line that I just want
cross it's cool it's it's a it's a great
little thing I mean is this like a rhino
Redemption Arc no it's just basically
designed to illustrate that the kinds of
things that Wilson Fisk is asking people
to do are things that not even villains
are willing to do more so than that it's
showing there's trouble in Paradise
right the foundations by which Wilson
Fisk is building his empire were never
stable to begin with and now now that
instability is showing in the fact that
it's starting to crack so it's really
really awesome to see what you also end
up getting in the aftermath of this is
that Miles basically ends up racing off
to the rest of the Avengers and then
telling them like Kingpin is after the
purple children right he's after the
kids of the purple man and that while I
was told by rhyo and sure I guess rhyo
is not necessarily the most credible
Force the guy saved our life right he
could he could kill us all with the
greatest of ease if he chose to but he
saved us and so if this is true and
Wilson Fisk is going after the purple
children having them under his control
being able to use their powers he'll
dominate the world while he'll be able
to take everything over and so it's one
of those crazy things because what you
end up getting here is this is this is
the just a crazy moment you switch over
to Wilson Fisk and Wilson Fisk of course
always having the staff next to him
which basically allows him to channel
the powers of the purple man is met by
tyo Mary now tyo Mary she's been around
in Daredevil comics for a long long time
she's had some great story arcs and
she's had some awful story arcs she's
like every kind book character ever
she's never had like 100% great arcs
100% of the
time that never happens but tyho Mary is
a person who basically has multiple
personality disorder right she's got
multiple personalities in her head some
of which have access to her powers and
others don't and her powers change
depending on which personality is taken
over right so like telepathy or
telekinesis or the ability to manipulate
Fire Imagine Legion but with far fewer
Personalities in his head and a far more
limited uh breadth of power at his
disposal and that's basically tied
before Mary right she's a mutant
essentially and so because of this the
the the interest between the two and
what's kind of intriguing is that one of
the things Kingpin says is he kind of
asked the question like why can't I stop
doing this right why hold on to these
things that cause me nothing but pain my
hatred my position I'm so consumed by
power and revenge but I have you I think
our fiery beginning and how it gave way
to something more powerful more
beautiful I think back on the first time
we made love after battle and now I find
I no longer need that battle to find
that level of satisfaction and so so in
the end typhoid says like I feel the
same thing right I feel the same way she
says even though I don't even really
remember our first time years of
treatments and Trauma have robbed me of
so much but I hold on to the feeling of
when we were first together and so
Wilson Fisk in turn says I wish we both
had those memories it doesn't feel fair
I wish you could remember and he invokes
the power of the purple man when he does
and tyo memory remembers everything she
remembers everything about her own past
now she doesn't run from Wilson Fisk
right she she doesn't like leave him
right it's just like she recalls
everything she's like oh my God what a
gift and so this is this is a whole
change to the power of the purple man
remember the power of zebidah killgrave
has only ever been used historically in
Marvel Comics to dominate The Wills of
others but here's something to
understand here's something to keep in
mind here we only ever saw his powers
used that way because he only ever used
them that way it wasn't as though
zebidah kilr was a guy who was trying to
find a way to make the world a better
place and he just simply couldn't do it
because his powers wouldn't let him the
guy's always been a dick right like zeid
kilgrave has always just been a horrible
human being who used his powers for like
personal gratification and for the
betterment of himself based on his own
selfish desires we've never seen an
instance when anybody ever used the
powers of the purple man to basically
get other people to remember and it kind
of makes sense right if the purple Man's
powers even if they're only by pheromone
can be used to make people do things and
even make people believe things then it
would stand to reason the powers of the
purple man can be used to make people
remember things and so in the in in
basically understanding that right in
coming to that realization fist says
like I need air right I need space the
weight of years is crushing me the
weight of hate that I so desperately
need to let go of and he says he
literally holds his thing in his hand
and says remember and this is when he
recalls the identity of Matt Murdoch as
Daredevil the question you really have
to ask here is what what else is Wilson
Fisk remembering because he is beset on
all sides by deception and trickery and
lies so what's going to happen when he
recalls everything that's actually the
truth and realizes how much he's been
lied to I got to tell you guys this
story just gets better and better so
Devil's Reign right this is amazing
remember what I told you guys about Mike
Murdoch that's probably what's going to
happen here or at least seems like is
happening here so initially coming off
the heels of the last video that we did
it was basically Kingpin using the
powers of the purple man on himself to
make him remember that Matt Murdoch is
Daredevil right that's one of the things
that I want to kind of reiterate here is
keep in mind everything that's happening
in Devil's Reign is because of the fact
that Kingpin could not remember what
Daredevil's identity was but knew that
he knew at some point in time and that
because Daredevil had haunted him he
came to the really the the realization
not so much a decision that Daredevil
had stripped him of his own identity and
so the results of this is that kingpin's
basically been harboring a grudge ever
since with this information coming back
now it's a blood Vendetta right it's not
even just like I need to know now it's
Daredevil's got to die right and I mean
it all kind of rushes back to him and
for him it's a massive betrayal right
one of the highest order and so when
he's told the Thunderbolts have
basically located the children of the
purple man remember they all basically
share a portion of his power and that if
purple man absorbs the powers of his
children his powers heightened several
times over when he's told we've located
where the children are but they've
basically dominated an an older woman
and they are living inside of a
residential building the response of
Kingpin is then go do it right go grab
them casualties be damned I don't care
how many people die grab those kids and
bring them in and so switching over to
the purple children of course they're
basically trying to figure out exactly
what it is that they're going to do the
goal is to free Zeb killgrave but what
essentially ends up happening is of
course there's a knock on the door when
they open it it is John Walker right us
agent there is part of the Thunderbolts
there to bring them in and when they try
to use their powers of course because
there's essentially mental blocks in
place and partially because of his
willpower that he ultimately is able to
overpower their abilities that this
essentially turns into the rest of the
Thunderbolts jumping in and then Electro
essentially shocking the entirety of the
purple kids and knocking them
unconscious now at that point that's
when you get into the involvement of the
Champions and it just kind of makes it
makes good sense right I mean I have a
hard time believing that anybody who's
reading Marvel Comics would support The
Avengers showing up and basically
pummeling the purple kids right just
beating up children no one's really
going to be okay with
that and so as essentially it's the
Champions jumping in as a way to
basically save their purple children now
I have to believe that one of the things
that chip sadarski is toying with here
is the possibility that we could
actually see the purple children
stepping in and becoming in some
capacity involved with the Champions but
the Champions are basically just the
teenage superheroes or the most popular
teenage superheroes in Marvel Comics
right that you got Kamala Khan you've
got Miles Morales and Sam Alexander Nova
and a couple others just the young
popular superheroes right they're kind
of like the cool kids table when it
comes to the superhero Community uh but
basically being there and saving them
right helping to rescue the purple
children it's one of those things where
it's like we could potentially have them
there now where the rest of the team
right what's left of the Avengers
essentially goes to face off against the
Thunderbolts suddenly Abomination
arrives on the scene now here's the
thing we never really have done a whole
lot of coverage when it comes to Emil
blansky right covering Abomination and
talking about his character he's not
necessarily on par with the Incredible
Hulk in so far as like the Incredible
Hulk gets stronger the more the the
angrier he gets but the Abomination is
no slap he's more than enough for
everybody here the other thing about
this is that he's basically a criminal
with a badge and because of the fact
that kingpen is approaching this from a
kind of by whatever means necessary
approach it means that that Abomination
has essentially permission to kill the
superheroes if he has to and he will
that's one of the big things right
Abomination would more than overpower
these superheroes and basically kill
them all and so where the purple
children are essentially captured by
Abomination the the whole thing is like
we have to go right like Miles Morales
and all them are like we have to leave
we can't stay here you know and with the
response of Jessica Jones is like no no
no we can't leave the kids here the like
Miles Morales is like you know I totally
get it right I mean but that's
Abomination right we'll save the kids at
some point in time but we can't do that
if we're dead and he will kill us so we
have to leave right now now at this
point we switch over to a combination or
I guess a conversation between Mike
Murdoch and Butch and the thing about
this is it's actually a reference to the
events from dear devil volume 6 annual
number one in 2020 and what it does is
it references the existence of a norn
stone now technically speaking Mike
Murdoch kind of has the norn stone in
his possession but not necessarily the
norstone was actually in the possession
of Parker Robbins of the hood and as you
guys know the hood is one of those guys
where he's just he's always had his
hands on everything he's had the casket
of ancient winners he's had a norstone
he's had The Infinity Gauntlet at one
point in time the guy had all kinds of
stuff right he's just one of these guys
where by whatever Manner and whatever
means he usually just ends up doing some
crazy things
Parker Robbins is a really cool
character and I really hope he joins the
MCU one day like as the hood but the
norstone as this explained to us in
terms of its use which is seemingly
what's going to apply here from
Daredevil annual that Parker Robbins
describes the norn stone as basically
being something that can rewrite reality
now while the norn stones have been
depicted in different ways over the
years in Marvel Comics in uh Spider-Man
or I guess symbat Spider-Man Crossroads
number four one of the things that was
given to us is that the norn stones were
seemingly created by the celestials in
the early days of the universe in order
to allow the celestials to explore other
realities to basically leave the
universe and explore other universes so
essentially the norn stones were keys to
the door that allowed them to access the
Multiverse whether or not that's still a
part of Marvel's continuity I'm not 100%
sure because the Practical use of the
norn stones has changed so much over the
years that they're not really based or
rooted in their original intention in
more recent years the norn stones have
just kind of become synonymous with the
Asgardian Mythos right so Thor and Odin
and all that kind of stuff especially
when you look at stories like uh Thor
disassembled or Thor Ragnarok as you as
you know it but the thing about this is
that if this Stone truly does have the
ability to rewrite reality that it was
presented or at least uh discussed by
Parker Robbins with Mike Murdoch it is
what was effectively a one-off right
like a one more day kind of thing right
you can use it once but it draws too
much heat so if you use it make sure
it's a big thing right it'll just draw a
lot of attention from all the wrong
people so it almost kind of seems like
to a degree Mike Murdoch has an Ace in
the Hole which is kind of hunting for it
to a degree but again it's one of those
things where he doesn't really seem to
believe in that kind of stuff you know
and so on and so forth but regardless
you switch back over to kingpen of
course meeting with Dr Octopus and his
alternate reality variants right The
Incredible Hulk Dr Octopus and wolver
rain and and Ghost Rider right those
variants of him and with the power of
the purple children being sent directly
into zebediah kilgrave that the response
of of Otto Octavius is okay Kingpin now
you have the power you need in order to
win the election and his response is I
don't care about the election right the
election isn't really relevant to me and
then he says do you know the reason why
it is that Spider-Man keeps defeating
you all the time and where 's like I
don't know he says because you think
short term you never think about the
bigger picture and this is true because
what happens here is that with Otto
Octavius being carried away with his own
mechan he never gave any thought to
Kingpin plotting against him and so
while he has his variants here Kingpin
who's still in possession of the purple
Man's power sees his control of the
variant of Otto Octavius and then has
them throw Otto out of a building right
like out of the building itself then he
directly constructs Zeb killgrave who
has an inhibitor collar on so his powers
can be used they can't really run aai
but in effect it allows Kingpin to
basically dominate uh Zeb killgrave or
at the very least killgrave possibly
doing it of his own accord he unleashes
them on the city and just says kill
every superhero you can find doesn't
matter who they are kill them all every
single superhero now this brings into
sharp relief the danger of Zeb killgrave
I've been saying this for the longest
time yes killgrave was really really
cool in Jessica Jones and in fact he was
the best part of that that show but the
reality of Zeb killgrave is he's a
massive threat right he is an Avengers
movie threat if the MCU ever decides to
change their tune and make another
Avengers film he could be a legitimate
Contender because all it would take is
for him to like walk into Avengers
mansion and just say everybody kill
yourselves and with the exception of
somebody like the Incredible Hulk who
you could actually finagle to fall under
the control of killgrave they would all
die right that's the level of power
killgrave has or he goes into the
Avengers mansion and takes over the team
and in the movie it plays out where he
uses the Avengers to conquer the world
it's not outside the realm of
possibility he is a highly slept on but
ridiculously overpowered character if
you write him the right way and put him
in the right circumstance right the guy
could easily hold a movie on his own the
other part of this is that for the
various members of the uh of the the
purple family as well as or I guess the
purple children as well as the Avengers
themselves that at the end of the day
they don't really want to see The
Avengers screw up and in fact there's
one point where a discussion is had
between uh between Luke Cage and
Daredevil uh basically with Joseph one
of the purple children and what they
tell him is like the purple man is is
100% evil the only time the only reason
the purple man hasn't used his powers to
just inflict Mass death and destruction
is because it just doesn't suit his
agenda but he could right he's done
nothing but destroy people's lives
that's all he does he just satisfies his
own personal gratification and cares
nothing about the people that he affects
and the result of this is that he says
the only way you're going to be able to
to defeat him is to kill him you're
going going to have to you're going to
have to kill purple man of course these
guys basically being superheroes Murdoch
says I totally get what you're saying
but we're not going to kill him right
he's like that's what separates us from
them we help people we save lives but
again it's that philosophical discussion
that we've brought up time and time
again what happens when you come across
someone who can't be saved every single
time they get out they inflict mass
destruction and harm is it one of those
things worse well we just lock them in
prison for the rest of their lives is
that really any better than killing them
you're basically just I mean it in some
places depending on who you talk to and
what psychological studies you read uh
death would actually be a more forgiving
punishment right you guys ever get a
chance look up the psychological studies
that deal with the idea of um of what is
it solitary confinement and how it'll
totally screw you up executing them is
preferable that they're kind of coming
from this perspective with somebody like
purple man and saying no we shouldn't
kill him we should just lock him up for
the rest of his life someone argue
that's cruel and unusual punishment
right you'd be better off just killing
it but regardless it's just one of those
things where it's kind of a
philosophical debate back and forth
between whether or not it's okay to kill
a villain that refuses to be redeemed
and so ultimately what ends up happening
here is of course you basically have a
coming together of the various autos and
so on right who just basically realize
that like you know now that they're out
of the influence of the purple man the
powers wear off and that they kind of
regain their normal cells and they're
there just in time to face off against
the Avengers who of course jump in and
so now it's essentially all the forces
of Kingpin versus all the forces of the
Avengers which leads to a mighty fight
right like a mini Civil War conflict but
a really cool conflict nonetheless right
it's it's just it's really really
awesome because what you end up getting
is Spider-Man says sorry Otto as usual
you don't rate very high on my list of
priorities unless you've seen a certain
purple man running around we'd love to
talk to him and this voice seemingly
comes out of nowhere and says of course
as long as you don't mind it being a
group conversation and this is what
makes things ridiculously difficult for
the Avengers and it's one of the things
that makes killgrave so cool he seized
control of the city of New York like
ultimately they're like he's got
everybody right like all these innocent
people just all these people are here
and they're all descending on The
Avengers what do you do here right
because each one of these people
controlled by the purple man will under
the influence of the purple Man fight to
the death in order to keep him alive so
how do you defeat the purple Man without
harming any innocent civilians I don't
know the answer to that question because
what we end up doing is switching over
to Mike Murdoch that once he seems to
get into his place that or at least
maybe Matt's place that what this is is
of course the whole the whole thing
being torn apart he ends up calling
Butch believing Butch is looking for the
norn stone that allows to rewrite
reality and all that kind of stuff but
when that happens he's met by the
arrival of Kingpin now remember Mike
Murdoch is the twin brother of Matt
Murdoch who was basically created into
existence accidentally by an inhuman
that could bring to life anything they
read and because Mike was an identity
that Matt had used at one point in time
Mike was accidentally brought into
existence by that guy's ability to
rewrite reality the problem is Kingpin
doesn't know this Kingpin looks at at at
Mike Murdoch and believes he's Matt now
part of this could also be because
kingpen is just absolutely incensed like
if he was more logical and more
reasonable he'd be able to understand
what's actually going on here in this
situation but the truth about it is that
he doesn't right he doesn't he's just
he's so pissed off that at the end of
the day he sees nothing but absolute
hatred and vitriol for Matt Murdoch that
when he looks at Mike he sees Matt now
one of the things that we said at the
beginning of this story we were kind of
explaining the nature of Mike Murdoch is
that he'd been around for a little while
but most likely what would happen is
that things would go in a direction to
where Marvel would basically write him
out and that's ex that's exactly what
looks like it happens here that
literally because what's going on
because he believes this Matt he takes
all his anger out on Mike believing uh
that he's basically been betrayed just
screaming at him like no more right like
no more stuff and just basically
seemingly beats him to death when
somebody walks in and sees him doing it
and he simply just says no more right
Kingpin loses his mind and beats who he
believes to be Daredevil to death in the
last issue we basically picked up or at
least we had this event where the purple
man who was basically being directed by
Wilson Fisk had essentially ens snared a
good chunk of the people in Manhattan
not all of them right not everybody but
a lot of them like certainly enough that
the Avengers have to face off against
them now there's also people like
Wolverine different things like that now
this is a bit of an inconsistency here
and here's the reason why so when it
comes to the powers of the purple man
remember they're basically a result of
phermones and so that's why people like
Wilson Fisk can overcome the power of
the purple man because their willpower
strong enough Wolverine technically
should not be in snare the other thing
that we have to to keep in mind though
is that this is not wolver rain from the
main Marvel Universe this is Dr Octopus
Wolverine and so looking at that and
looking at like the Dr Octopus
Incredible Hulk both of which are from
alternate realities that seemingly they
have the same nature and structure of
like wolver rain and the Incredible Hulk
but they lack the components that would
help them to resist the power of the
purple man so it is kind of a wave for
chip zadarski to basically say maybe in
some former fashion Wolverine could
potentially be corrupted by the purple
man uh although given Marvel's
traditional history again that's not
something we would readily see so I felt
like that was something worth pointing
out because I imagine a lot of people
who didn't pick up on the fact that this
is like the Dr Octopus alternate reality
version of wol rain would be like that
doesn't make any sense wol rain in the
main Marvel Universe should not be
caught up by the purple man you're right
it's just a different version of the
character but the bigger thing that goes
on here is that the superheroes who are
not ens snared by the purple man have to
contend with like the average person
right just your your normal Average
Joe's and that's kind of a big deal
because they they have to basically keep
them at Bay they have to fight them off
but they don't want to hurt them at the
same time which is kind of the benefit
of the purple man here because it's
basically taking the nature of the
superheroes and using it against them
the bigger thing that goes on here
though is that in the middle of this
fight Matt Murdoch gets a call that Mike
has been killed now here's the thing
when when Matt Murdoch gets this call
he's basically told that Matt is dead
right because at the end of the day Kon
McDuffy does not know that Matt Murdoch
is Daredevil but as you guys know Matt's
twin brother is Mike and so while Matt's
like okay that's weird cuz I'm alive and
well he immediately picks up on the fact
that what Kon actually saw was Wilson
Fisk killing Mike moch and so that's
when he realizes his brother's basically
dead now we called this right
like we said Mike Murdoch was going to
die we like it's only a matter of time
before it happens because he's a
character that doesn't really serve a
purpose anymore and so Marvel was like
we'll just get rid of him and just
replace him with somebody else it's one
of the things right you read Marvel
Comics enough long enough you can figure
out where they're going with particular
characters when they stop using them for
anything significant after a while but
the death of Mike is not limited to how
it impacts Matt in fact it'll also uh
it'll also impact the son of kingpen
Butch and we'll talk about him here in a
little while but again doing what they
can here at least the various
superheroes facing off against these
various villains Daredevil ultimately
ends up taking off to basically find
Wilson Fisk with the intention of
killing Wilson Fisk because Wilson Fisk
had killed his brother Matt now this is
an important thing and in a lot of ways
while it does kind of focus on sort of a
a coming two of this battle between like
Wilson Fisk and Daredevil the reality is
that this is a long time coming and
while there have been stories in the
past where like Matt Murdoch just start
just gives Wilson fist the business for
any number of reasons this has a kind of
finality to it right like the final
fight between like Batman and the Joker
or like the final fight between Superman
and Lex Luther this kind of seems to fit
that mold in a lot of different ways
because the reality here is that Wilson
Fisk has done a lot of things to get
back at at Daredevil he's dumped his
identity to the world technically it was
Karen page who sold the identity of of
Daredevil as uh as Matt Murdoch but
nonetheless there's been a lot of things
that Wilson Fisk has done but this is
one of those things where it's kind of
the straw that broke the camels back
Wilson Fisk in terms of killing Mike
Murdoch believing he'd actually killed
Matt at the same time doing all this
stuff in terms of like outlawing
superheroes and so on and so forth it's
one of those things where Matt's like
enough right like this is like enough is
enough this guy's got to die now make no
mistake for Matt it's personal right
it's a very personal thing because
Wilson Fisk going after superheroes or
whatever right that's just Wilson Fisk
doing what you ultimately would have
expected him to do as the mayor of New
York it was only a matter of time
killing the brother of Matt Murdoch
that's breaking a line right that's
crossing a line that just is not
acceptable and so from there you
basically switch over to Wilson Fisk
meeting with tyho Mary now again the two
of them are basically a couple right
they're romantically involved with each
other but Wilson Fisk believing he'
killed Matt had told her we're done like
everything's done like it's just time to
go it's time to walk away the problem is
that as they're leaving they're suddenly
met by Electra now remember remember
Electra is kind of like a a neerish
version of of Daredevil now at the
moment uh Electra is kind of like this
kind of Daredevil kind of
not right she's sort of doing her own
thing she had taken up the mantle when
Daredevil was basically locked up and
just hadn't given it up right it was
just a way for Marvel to kind of be like
we're elevating Electra Beyond basically
the old Frank Miller days when she was
just the chick that was hot that Matt
Murdoch probably banged a few times and
uh she's just a really good assassin
right and instead like they're moving
her into to a different Echelon where
it's really her and Matt Murdoch working
as a team and in reality this is long
overdue right like Electra's literally
been one of those characters where she's
just been the same character forever so
it's cool to see Marvel despite the fact
that it's something they haven't really
done since the ' 80s it's cool to see
Marvel just Elevate her and move her in
a different direction and give her like
a holy different role that's far beyond
anything she's ever done before
particularly in the realm of Daredevil
Comics so I'm definitely digging that
but in the midst of this of course where
she's going to attack kingpen ultimately
Matt's like no if Kingpin dies today or
when he dies today I'll be the last
thing he sees and the crazy thing is
that like like Wilson fist doesn't know
what to do here because he thought he
killed Matt and he's like why won't you
simply just die and ultimately of course
the two of them end up getting into a
skirmish now there are a couple things
that go on for example like Dr Octopus
is attacked by Iron Man and basically
knocked unconscious the Fantastic Force
step in and they kind of do their thing
which is cool I guess whatever uh but
like the the thing about this and really
one of the bigger things that take place
is that one the really the last of the
purple Man's children essentially Joseph
ends up stepping up right ends up coming
into the equation now one of the things
that chip sidari has largely built up
and has has really been a contingent or
a thing that's been going on with the
purple children since their initial
introduction is that they could
potentially overpower the purple man to
a degree he actually needed their powers
in order to basically expand on his own
but Joseph there was always something
different about him and so ultimately
where he kind of makes his way and
you've just got this knockdown drag out
fight between like Wilson Fisk and uh
and Daredevil and you've got Electra
fighting Typhoid Mary and all that kind
of stuff you've basically got the purple
man just literally seething with power
right I mean just just full of power
that the question that Joseph asks once
he finds him is where where like where's
everybody else right like where are the
other kids and that's when the purple
man's like they're dead right like I
have their power now and there's nothing
you can do to stop me and so it
basically comes to a fight between uh
purple man and his son now this is the
reason why this matters because what
this really is despite the fact that
this is a crossover event in Marvel
comics and it focuses on a lot of the
superheroes it's the same thing we've
been saying since the beginning it's a
daredevil story that what this does is
it basically brings together and and
really ties up all these Loose Ends
involving the Daredevil Mythos that's
been going on for quite some time since
the return of the purple children and
all that kind of stuff and there's even
themes of this that go all the way back
into like Brian Michael bend' New
Avengers specifically with Luke Cage
we'll talk about him here in a second
but it's one of those things where it
literally just wraps up the Daredevil
Mythos that's been going on for quite
some time and it just sort of resets it
now that's one of the things that I love
about the idea of Devil's Reign is
because under any normal circumstance
and those of you guys who've been
reading comics for a long time you guys
know under any normal circumstance this
would have been wrapped up in a
daredevil comic and that would have been
it it would have been Daredevil's issues
such and such through such and such and
that would have been it it's just one of
those things where making it like a
high-profile crossover event really sort
of elevates it and it's just like this
is basically the conclusion of this era
of Daredevil and that's basically it and
that's why you could go back and read
all those Comics Charles soul and
everything going all the way up until
the current age until this story and
it's one cohesive era it's just one
giant Daredevil epic and so at the end
of that of course again this giant fight
between uh between Daredevil and Kingpin
it begins to come to a head when
basically Daredevil's just like thrown
into a car right and like really injured
and then he grabs the staff of Kingpin
which contains a portion of the purple
Man's power and when he says like I want
you to suffer Kingpin like I want you to
suffer for all the things that you've
done I want you to think about all the
lives that you've destroyed he's just
like done right and then just goes back
to attacking Daredevil because again
Wilson fisk's fortitude right his his
just willpower overrides the power of
the purple man and that's why I say
killgrave is a really really cool
villain but he only works under certain
circumstances that's why like the
Jessica Jones story in Alias by Bendis
was so good is because she was just a
young naive superhero who had no idea
what she was getting into when she
stumbled across the path of the purp man
because her willpower just wasn't quite
there yet she hadn't sort of she hadn't
really built herself up and gained the
confidence she needed in order to
overpower the influence of the purple
man now she does right if Zeb kilgrave
goes running up on Jessica Jones she's
going to scoff off his powers and then
beat the hell out of him that's exactly
what's going to happen those two have
beef but it's just it's it's really
really cool right it's just one of those
cool elements and so knowing that
doesn't necessarily work then we switch
over to Luke Cage because at this point
this fight between uh Daredevil and and
Wilson Fisk is just an intense fight
just like a knockdown drag out fight and
that's why you have these moments where
you have chips darki sort of bouncing
back and forth between these scenarios
where like Matt murdog cracks Kingpin
across the face with his own cane right
and literally just like just creates
these gashing wounds and like Wilson
Fisk is just pummeling just absolutely
attacking Daredevil as best he can
they're literally trying to kill each
other right it's just Decades of hatred
at least in terms of comic publication
history coming to a head in this story
but for Luke Cage he makes this amazing
moment where what he does is he
basically takes his takes the device
that's used to basically uh ensure that
he's not influenced by the purple man
and he gives it to Joseph so that way
Joseph won't be overpowered by his own
father and that's when killgrave is like
that's a ridiculous thing and he says Mr
cage kill my son and that's the cool
thing is because where Luke Cage looks
like he's getting ready to kill him and
destroy this kid this kid starts lashing
out and what luk cage says is like
you're not alone Joseph like you are not
by yourself I know you feel like you are
but you are not tap into your power son
and use it now you would look at this
and you would say okay Luke Cage should
suum come to the power of the purple man
there's never been an indication to show
that he can't overpower him but there
actually is so in Brian Michael Bend's
New Avengers in the first Arc right
breakout which I don't know if you ever
covered that but bis's New Avengers was
phenomenal right it was like it's
probably one of the best Brian Michael
Bendis stories ever before he lost his
mind and started going into Bendis speak
before he got carried away with himself
there was a point because killgrave was
locked away in the raft and Luke Cage
was in his presence he actually
instructed Luke Cage to basically start
attacking the superheroes and if I
remember correctly Luke Cage was able
overpower it he was able to like
override the influence of the purple man
and that was basically it it took every
ounce of inner strength for him to do it
but he was still able to do it but with
Joseph using every ounce and and really
it's more emotion than anything else
right but like tapping into this power
to influence others he overrides the
power of his father and by overriding
the power of his dad he solidifies
himself as being stronger than the
purple man which is huge because of
course as you would expect where
Daredevil is on the cusp of killing
Wilson Fisk of course he doesn't and
things wrap up pretty readily right like
the the various members of the
Thunderbolts are arrested as you would
expect the Thunderbolts were always
arrested right they're always just
locked up and taken to a prison
somewhere until they need to be used
again and then they're basically
released and they're sent out on
whatever task they have to go on right
so Marvel's version of The Suicide Squad
uh of course again Wilson Fisk is
arrested the purple man is basically
taken away but what it does is it clears
the landscape here and allows for
reshuffling of things because now you
have Joseph as what's basically the
purple child you know where he still
like has his powers and that nobody else
really does he's just the last of the
the a person who can use the abilities
of the purple man so he's out there now
and presumably he's going to become a
good guy so we won't know how his story
unfolds I mean presumably it'll appear
in some comic I don't really see them
making a solo comic for him specifically
even though I would probably read it I'd
read the first couple the first Arc just
to see whether or not it's good uh and
it may even be one of those things where
like Jessica Jones and Luke Cage end up
adopting him right end up taking him in
and just kind of he just goes forward
and does his own thing Wilson Fisk where
he's being arrested you end up finding
out that what's actually going on here
is that Butch is one of the people who
had arrested him Butch being his son and
they basically end up taking him away to
what's essentially a safe haven now when
he gets there it's actually Butch
bringing him to the presence of the St
WIS now here's the thing the St winds
are basically new for chips sidari's
work but we don't really know a whole
lot about them all we really know is
that they've just kind of appeared
intermittently so like Daredevil Volume
6 issue number 13 they were part of uh
of Devil's Reign but in effect they were
the one on who have essentially gotten
Wilson Fisk this far in terms of him
becoming mayor building on what happened
during secret Empire when like he was
the one that was keeping New York safe
and so on and so forth they seem to be
the benefactors and so what they end up
saying here is look like you got a
couple options here Wilson Fisk right
the whole world knows what you did uh
but we have a lot of reach and we have a
lot of pool and we can really help you
know these these charges that are being
brought against you we can help them go
away the way this will work though is
that your son will basically become the
Kingpin in the city of New York and then
we will Elevate you to the office of the
presidency we'll make you president of
the United States right using our
finances and so on and so forth we will
get you to that spot and that in reality
while you will be president you'll
essentially be working for us right like
we'll be telling you what kind of bills
you need to veto what kind of bills you
need to pass any executive orders that
need to be issued you know make no
mistake we'll be the ones controlling
the scene but you will get what you've
always wanted you'll become president
and you get this amazing moment where
Wilson Fisk you know where they
literally go to shake his hand and he's
just kind of like this is an interesting
offer now it's very similar to clone
conspiracy right when like the Jackal
had shown up to Wilson Fisk with a
cloned version of Vanessa and he freaked
out snapped her neck and was like that's
not my wife that's not Vanessa that's
exactly what happens here right he says
my life has been successes and failures
I let my wife Vanessa down in the sense
that she died and my son Richard and now
to be president running a country he
says how could Butch not look up to me
and respect me then because remember for
the longest time he didn't know Butch
existed and then when Butch finally came
around he was always trying to
demonstrate that he was like an
effective man but as a guy who was
essentially taking orders from the Str
ons even as mayor of New York that they
were the ones who got them there or at
least got him there that it was always
one of these things where he felt like
in the eyes of his son that he was a
follower that he wasn't a leader that
the Wilson FIS of old had largely seemed
to have gone away right and now he was
just doing what a good boy does and so
again he says how could Butch not look
up to me and respect me then running the
greatest country in the world and he
says I've made mistakes
I won't make another and literally he's
like Fisk bows to no one and just starts
crushing everybody like literally starts
attacking everybody the guards the St
ons the whole nine yards the whole time
he's like crushing the hand of one of
the St ones and then literally everybody
just gets taken out right like they're
just basically done and gone and that's
when he's like here's what's going to
happen right he tells his son like when
his son's like what are you doing he's
like the exact same thing you're doing
like you're joining in here he's like
look a Fisk does not bow to anyone a
Fisk does not take orders from anyone a
Fisk does as Fisk pleases and that's the
way that it is because we're powerful
enough because we have enough conviction
only a fool would come to a Fisk and say
work for me and I will give you X Y and
Z when a Fisk knows full well they can
just take it and he's like that's the
Legacy that I leave to you he was like
you are now the Kingpin of New York I'm
out I'm going to do my thing but I leave
you this Legacy live up to the legacy of
the Fisk do not let anybody out there
tell you what you will or will not do if
there is something that you want take it
and those who are too weak will let you
have it and those who were too strong
would be stupid enough to challenge you
so do what you please that's the way we
as FIS operate he's like after all these
years this is my gift to you boy your
inheritance and walks away now during
this conversation what he had let slip
is that he had murdered Matt Murdoch and
that ultimately this is when Butch
realizes it was not Matt Murdoch that
kingpen killed it was Mike Murdoch it
was his friend and so as a result of
that the question's kind of up in the
air what happens next does Butch live up
to the legacy of the Fist or does Butch
basically become a good guy and actually
turn against his father does he become
an ally of Daredevil we're not entirely
sure but the week following this this is
when we start to get a kind of uh kind
of followup this is really more of like
a epilogue this just tied directly into
the story and really gives us the next
direction for the Daredevil series which
is that electron naos and and Matt
Murdoch are essentially teaming up to
form the fist that what they are going
to do is basically become this kind of
antithesis of the hand now in recent
years and and not even really recent
years but like in years past that was
the role that was played by the cast the
reality of this is that they're not
really a part of the picture anymore and
so because of that something has to
stand against the role of the hand
always influencing and always involving
things but the reason why the hand is
chosen make no mistake the reason why
that group is chosen as being uh being
really the the main enemy of the Fist is
because this is taking Daredevil back to
the old school days it's tying back into
the Frank Frank Miller days even if it's
not necessarily retreading water it's
bringing back the classic Daredevil but
by a different means and it's instead of
Electra just being some assassin out
there that Matt Murdoch crosses paths
with and touches naughty bits with every
so often instead like she's an ally
right she's working with him and the two
of them are going to go forward with
their fist and then do their whole thing
so that's cool and I'm actually
interested to see what direction this
ends up going in as for Wilson Fisk and
the way this basically ends Wilson Fisk
ends up doing what he always felt like
he should have done before that the
reality here is that with him operating
as the Kingpin of crime that he always
basically took directions from other
people that even when he was operating
as Kingpin and even when he was to a
degree doing his own thing his life was
motivated by trying to defeat Daredevil
or something along those lines and
seemingly for the first time he's
literally taking his life under his own
under his own wing and just like taking
uh taking tyo Mary and just like going
out into the world where their Journey
takes them I'm not entirely sure but I
would surmise the reason why they're
doing this the reason why Marvel's doing
this doesn't really have much to do with
the nature of Kingpin and Marvel Comics
is because kingpin's in the MCU and the
last we saw him he was shot in the face
by Eko at least presumably anyway right
the camera panned off and then we heard
a gunshot and then maybe kingpin's dead
but supposedly he's going to come back
is what everybody's saying right he's
supposed to reappear in the MCU Series
in the actual Marvel Cinematic Universe
series on Disney plus which fingers
crossed is going to be mature just like
it was on on Netflix and likely when
that happens they'll bring him back in
some capacity similar to that right so
when that series launches or when yeah
when that series Launches on Disney plus
and like the Kingpin returns this is
when you'll see Marvel be like the
kingpin's back in the comics you know
like that's going to their whole thing
right so with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end I did love
devil Devil's Reign don't get me wrong I
thought it was a phenomenal Story I mean
it's just beautifully written and
beautifully done uh I I thought it was
incredible but let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later peace